Hello again, this is Dr. Cutters here at section five of the stop fighting cancer book and
Digging into
Get a little bit of my background the reason why I kid we I wanted to put together
You know a little presentation with it and break up the sections
And I actually added pieces to the book that you won't get if you just purchased the book in these in these downloadable sections
Because there's things that are always updating. I added a ton of new research information
In this in the in the sections to come this section. I have some hidden studies that you're going to be able to uncover
I'm constantly studying. I am addicted to that
Honestly, I asked my wife. I have no other life. I'm kind of a boring person, but that's just the way it is
This is a colleague to me. This our our clinic is a ministry. It is it is
It really is so this is our purpose in life
So again, we're looking for the cause. What is started this in the first place?
How are we gonna make changes and always I'm gonna tell you my patients and I'll tell you you never become my patient
Be seeking God's face. There is a reason that this is going on in your life if this is cancer
It if this is a loved one that you're reading this information for and and trying to grasp that straws
Always be looking to him to seek his face
He has some answers for you. You know that he loves you beyond anything you can ever imagine
And that is the most important thing to come to understand
Just have that complete utter dependence upon him. He loves you more than anything
In this section, we're gonna look to how why is it so difficult to uncover the truth?
Why don't we read about alternative approaches in the news? Why doesn't our local television station
Talk about alternative approaches to cancer and yet they so readily jump on some
uh
recent
news press release
From a pharmaceutical company about some ridiculous new medication they have for something
well
I talked about looking at the biases and you do have to look at
The who advertises on these stations who and who's the largest advertiser of
Fox News or NBC or CBS and ABC
The largest advertisers are pharmaceutical companies
uh
alcohol companies
They're never going to write bashing articles or
A publicize the number of people that died from the Gardasil vaccination
Which happens to be you have a hundred percent
Greater chance of dying from the Gardasil vaccination then dying from cervical cancer and yet you'd never read about that
so
In this section there are a bunch of hidden studies that might help you
At least give if you've if you've chosen to go an alternative approach already
If you a little ammunition when you're talking to people at church or loved ones or friends that are functioning and livid out of fear and and
Almost angry at you because you're not doing exactly what the medical establishment is pushing you to
Or you're not solely doing this um again recognize
I'm not ever against standard medicine. I think it offers us wonderful results at a lot of things
But you also have to look at a bigger approach. You have to take a step back and have
A done dogmatic position. So that's my biggest argument. You don't want to take a dogmatic position against modern medicine
Either I think that's equally wrong. You just want to take a step back and be wise and say what's the best thing for me
Is it to do chemo? Well, maybe it is but then I need to do these other things to help combat the negative effects of chemo
And just be wise about it and it's it's really foolish to just be
Be blind to other avenues. I think that's very important
So enjoy these hinted studies remember our four major pillars and I will see you at the next presentation